what is lacking nutrient-wise when you
have a split nail
whether it's in your fingernail or your
toenail there's a medical condition
called anacostia this is a fancy turn
for
you have brittle nails or split nails
soft nails
fin nails or peeling of your nails
now it could be low iron
in some cases could be low amounts of
biotin
but the most likely cause is low calcium
it's a calcium deficiency now
you could also be low in vitamin d
that's preventing you from absorbing
calcium
but this is the most common reason for
split nails
all right the best calcium source would
be something like calcium lactate
calcium orotate calcium citrate but do
not do the calcium
carbonate okay why because
it takes like 12 different steps for
your body to absorb that
and you could also do a high quality
cheese as well like
maybe organic grass-fed cheese from
europe
that would be also a good way to get
your calcium
other symptoms of a calcium deficiency
would be fatigue
weak grip strength muscle aches
twitching weakened bones
they're brittle or you have cramping it
could be in your feet it could be
in your calf there's some other symptoms
as well
like little tingling around your lips
like
it's called paresthesia but this is
probably the most likely reason why you
have split nails
and you can easily get some calcium
lactate or oratate or citrate
and resolve this problem all right
thanks for watching
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today